c'est un truc de malade
je suis vraiment malade et le court
encore dit vieux comme ça on voit des
copains un trottoir
mais si tu veux gerber soit sympa
installe toi plutôt à l'arrière- penche
toi essais butait loi partez à la
recherche de mes parents au diadème de
la tente une lavette moraux auxquels il
ya pas longtemps clamé moi mes revenus
alors je suis pas très sûr mais quelque
chose me dit que doivent être plutôt
bleu avec une pointe de julien deschamps
je suis sûr que je le reconnaîtrai dès
que les verrez l'air de famille
moi je dis que la traversée de l'océan
c'est le genre de croisière qu'il faut
avoir fait une fois dans sa vie une
seule et clope à la prochaine sortie
si c'est le reprends toi la girouette ou
6e b bonjour je m'appelle dirige c'est
aussi en quoi comme le dit moi je suis
pas mal d'eau mises en quarantaine au
nom il reste combien de temps à vivre
il faut aujourd'hui les parents à
l'arête aux courbes ou au non c'est pas
bon ça qu'est-ce qui se passe très
mauvaise nouvelle c'est une étiquette de
transport pour les poissons qu'on aucune
chance à l'institut on les transfère
dans un lieu de vie définitif un
aquarium
ma famille je ne deviens pas
et ce jour là quelque part il faut que
je les trouve vous mettrez à trouver
et vous c'est toi qui a disparu mes
parents je me rappelle c'est yann moix
qu'est-ce que tu te rappelles je me
souviens de mes parents ma mère mon père
j'ai une famille ils ne savent pas où je
suis non non c'est la folie où tu peux
aller d'abord bao au diamant de la
baltique joyeux de l'avesnois en
californie ces salons dorés la
californie c'est de l'autre côté de
l'océan la faille aller et enfin
pourquoi chaque fois qu'on est aux
portes agressif il faut qu'il y en ait
un qui prennent le large qu'on ne
pourrait pas se contenter de jouir de la
vue qui me parle de la vue alors que j'y
viens de te dire que je me souviens de
mes parents donc les grands voyages
c'est terminé mais attend pour tous dans
la vie j'ai déjà voyagé je sais de quoi
je parle le meilleur moment dans le
voyage c'est quand on rentre à la maison
s'ennuierait de parler moins fort j'ai
mal à la tête qui s simon fouassin pays
là il est arrivé que de blessures hawks
je sais que tu parle de moi d'espérer
qu'il peut plus servir de son sonar mais
j'ai entendu les médecins 10 juin
absolument tout ce que tu dis sur moi
c'est quoi un sonar normalement la tête
de bellême et des ultrasons et
l'écholocalisation lui permet de repérer
des objets à distance mais apparemment
monsieur n'est pas encore guéri ok donc
là c'est sûr tu parles demain je
réellement perdu l'écholocalisation vue
c'est toujours la même excitation je me
suis violemment cognée la tête parce que
ça c'est pas une bosse peut-être c'est
tout à fait normal pour un béluga
d'avoir une grosse tête
attendre non non non je sais où sont mes
parents un descendant là c'est quoi déjà
la bassine dans le garage barça grand
large le baça grand large le bassin
grand large
je sais c'est le grand bassin qui est
juste à côté de débrouille toi tout seul
et tu arrêtes 1 le mieux pour rejoindre
le bassin grand large
c'est par les tuyaux par les tuyaux
voilà par les tuyaux wii prend deux fois
à gauche et ensuite c'est tout droit à
ça alors c'est compliqué à retenir donc
tu as entendu tu t'en souviens
oui formidable amis si je peux pas venir
avec doit juger trop gros vas-y tout
seul c'est que c'est à dire que je peux
pas je sais pas j'ai pas trop le sens de
l'orientation
c'est dommage mais ce qui est convenu
est convenu tu veux retrouver tes
parents c'est par là donne-moi
l'étiquette je peux pas y aller tout
seul je serai plongerait pas mon
problème
l'étiquette